good morning ladies and gentlemen on
behalf of the president of Yale
University the commanding officer of
Yale naval Reserve Officers Training
Corps and Commander of Yale Air Force
Reserve officer training Corps welcome
to the annual president's review
we specifically acknowledge and thank
representatives in attendance from
Fairfield University Quinnipiac
University Sacred Heart University
Southern Connecticut State University
Western Connecticut State University and
the University of New Haven to you and
to all distinguished guests families and
friends welcome
today's music is provided by the United
States Navy Band Northeast today's
review is conducted by the midshipmen
and Cadets of Yale Naval and Air Force
Reserve officer training Corps
present-day reviews have their basis in
both history and tradition the mass
formation of troops on one long line at
close interval made possible the massing
of Firepower from muzzle loaded muskets
of yesterday
in those early days the line of battle
was just that a line of two or three
rings and looked much like the parade
formation you will see today the
adjutant forms a line for battle
thank you
so attention
[Music]
[Applause]
ready here we go
[Music]
foreign
Ultra
clearwell
[Music]
[Applause]
well
prison
all present
very well
order
[Music]
I said
what
thank you
[Applause]
sword
ladies and Gentlemen please rise for the
arrival of the official party
Air Force Reserve officer training Corps
unit Detachment
009 arriving
naval Reserve officer training Corps
unit Yale University arriving
[Music]
Yale University arriving
ladies and Gentlemen please remain
standing for the posting of the colors
the national anthem and the invocation
thank you
praise God
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
chaplain Sharon coedler Yale University
chaplain will now give the invocation
good morning
please join me in a spirit of Prayer
almighty God source of all truth
Here We Stand humbled by the breadth of
service both past and present in our
midst
We Stand proud of what has been made
possible because we have committed
ourselves to making your world a better
place through our willing spirits able
bodies and courageous hearts
although today is a celebration and
rightly so
we remember those who have given their
lives in service to their country and we
hold close those who are currently
deployed and ask that your gentle hand
protect them and guide them safely home
now may our hearts move from gratitude
to inspiration as your Divine Spirit
empowers us with a renewed vision and
purpose
let us begin this review lifted by
Splendor ignited by camaraderie
together in our many voices strengths
and faiths as your loving people we say
Amen
please be seated
the president's review has several
purposes first it serves to honor and
thank the leadership of the universities
that host and support our units this
event also serves as an opportunity to
publicly recognize the achievements of
the midshipmen and Cadets you see here
today who have distinguished themselves
during the Academic Year ladies and
gentlemen commanding officer Yale
University naval Reserve officer
training Corps Captain Ron Withrow
good morning everyone
president salave General Raymond fellow
ROTC commanders ROTC representatives
from our partner colleges and
universities
Provost Strobel Dean Lewis Yale
administrators faculty and staff alumni
and supporters who I will collectively
refer to as friends of ROTC award
presenters representing a host of
organizations friends and families
welcome all to the Yale ROTC president's
review
this is a great opportunity to showcase
our Yale ROTC midshipmen and Cadets
recognize our top performers and also
recognize our graduating class of 2023
who will be commissioning in just a few
short weeks
this event wouldn't be possible without
the hard work from several outstanding
individuals I want to especially thank
Marine option midshipman third class
Evan Kwong the midshipman officer in
charge response for planning this Grand
Event U.S Marine Corps Gunnery Sergeant
Chaz King for providing drill instructor
grade instruction our senior
administrative coordinator Liz vildaki
for coordinating with numerous
supporting organizations and our MC U.S
Marine Corps Captain ratsby May and many
many others
before I introduce our reviewing officer
president salave for his remarks I want
to talk to you a bit about history Duty
and Leadership
for those of you seeing this for the
first time today the president's review
consists of an award ceremony and a
military pass interview
so first a bit of History regarding the
past interview to expound on what the MC
Captain May has already stated
the passing review is a formal
time-honored ceremony dates back to
before the Civil War the purpose of the
ceremony was to formally present the
military command to a new Commander or
commanding officer probably most
probably visible to most of you would be
the pass and review before the newly
sworn in president of the United States
commander-in-chief which follows the
inaugural ceremony another example would
be the past review conducted at the
recruit graduation ceremonies marking
the completion of boot camp and
enlistment into active duty one in which
this guy participated in in 1985 by the
way and yet I retained my youthful
appearance or at least I keep telling
myself that when I look in the mirror
every morning
the military pass review has transformed
over time to also include honoring the
hard work and dedication of military
members in the performance of their
duties as we will do today
so what are the duties of cadets and
midshipmen
they're not only college students but
distinguish themselves by committing to
serve their countries future soldiers
Sailors Marines Airmen and Guardians
they carry the same course load that
other students on campus carry
participating in and leading the same
diverse palette of extracurricular
activities Sports Student Government
Affinity groups etc etc
but they are different and that they
have taken an oath to serve their
country in preparation to defend their
freedoms and the Liberties that all U.S
citizens enjoy
committing to undergoing intensive
instruction to prepare them and in fact
transform them
mentally morally and physically into
Warriors and the profession of arms
and now looking specifically at our
seniors who will be commissioning in
just a few short weeks I know each of
you have been giving considerable
thought to the oath of office that you
will take as current Navy service Chief
Admiral Mike gilday stated the oath is
what binds us together it is the
foundation of our profession it is our
North Star it defines us
wise words that apply equally to all
because Cadets in midshipmen no matter
the color of the uniform the oath is the
same and it will Define you and ladies
and gentlemen looking at the world we
live in today we need this creative and
energetic young men and women more than
ever to lead our armed forces in the
coming critical years
last year vice admiral Roy Kitchener
he's the head of our surface Navy hosted
a junior officer training Symposium that
was titled embracing Ingenuity to
sharpen her Competitive Edge
but this wasn't simply training for
these young leaders they weren't in
receive only mode Admiral Kitchener used
the Symposium to Foster wide-ranging
discussion centered on building
efficiencies within the force improving
business practices and as a venue for
junior officers to present current
challenges in the surface force that
they saw along with proposed Solutions
why because as the Admiral stated Junior
officers play an integral role in
solving problems on the waterfront
commandant of the U.S Marine Corps
General David Berger shared similar
sentiments when he stated small unit
leaders who are well trained
who have experienced a maturity make
decisions and are empowered to make
decisions in lieu of detailed guidance
are powerful even when outnumbered and
even went up against formations that are
two three four times as big this is the
bread and butter of the Marine Corps I
acknowledge these are naval-centric
examples that I've given but the Navy
and Marine Corps certainly doesn't hold
a monopoly on challenging problems in
the need to solve them I'm sure all
service branches agree that we must look
to these enterprising energetic and
creative young men and women for
Solutions whether we are talking about
the Navy's get real get better mindset
the Army's people first winning matters
transformational philosophy where the
Air Forces accelerate change or lose
strategic Approach at the end of the day
without intelligent creative committed
and empowered leaders Manning our
enlisted and officer ranks they're just
cliched empty catchphrases it takes real
concern real leadership and a
willingness to get into the fight make
mistakes and try try again so to get at
the midshipman standing here on behalf
of all the commanders present I charge
each of you to be the transformable
transformational Junior leaders and
decision makers that our nation needs
because good leadership does not just
Propel the military forward it also
propels our nation and our world forward
and we in ROTC enjoy a great partnership
with Yale in this regard working
together to develop intelligent caring
and collaborative leaders to transform a
world for the better critical to this
partnership has been the leadership and
The Guiding vision of President Peter
salovey Yale's mission statement reads
in part that Yale educates aspiring
leaders worldwide who serve all sectors
of society
one can easily see the similarity in
missions and how this contributes to a
supportive effective partnership this is
no doubt a direct reflection of
President salave's inspirational
leadership and vision so at this time I
would like to introduce our reviewing
official and host the 23rd president of
Yale University and the Chris argaris
professor of psychology Peter salave
[Applause]
so much appreciate that
thank you Captain Withrow I appreciate
the kind introduction
and I'd also like to thank Colonel
granholm for his inspired leadership of
Yale's Air Force Reserve Officers
Training Corps unit
both Captain Withrow and Colonel
granholm will be retiring after this
semester
and so before I proceed any further I
want to offer my heartfelt appreciation
and that of a grateful Yale community
for both of your commitments to
advancing stability in the world as we
wish you both the very best for the
wonderful new chapter on which you are
about to Embark we know that you will
remain very much a part of the Yale
family
with the approach of their retirements
please join me in recognizing Captain
Ron Withrow and Colonel George Graham
home's exceptional service to this
country
thank you they have been wonderful
leaders here on our campus
to all the parents loved ones active
duty military members veterans here
extend a warm greeting on behalf of my
colleagues across the University
and I wish to welcome Cadets Liaisons
and leaders here today
from our air force-affiliated
universities Fairfield University
Quinnipiac University Sacred Heart
University Southern Connecticut State
University University of New Haven
Wesleyan University and Western
Connecticut State University
the sense of service we mark on this
historic occasion dates to the founding
of our Institution
and of the Republic
here are just a few examples in 1701
Yale became the first American
University to inscribe service to
society explicitly
in its founding legislation
scores of yalis have served with
distinction in every major conflict
since the Revolutionary War
Yale Air Force ROTC was one of the
original 77 senior air ROTC units
established by an order General
Eisenhower signed
and Yale was also among the initial
group of universities to establish an
ROTC program more than a century ago
Army ROTC in 1917 followed by Naval ROTC
in 1926 and Air Force ROTC in 1946.
at the time Major General Robert M
Danford predicted the program would
become one of the many Priceless
heritages of future Generations at Yale
when I look out at all of you
I can see that he was right
the 55 Air Force Cadets and the 31
midshipmen currently participating in
Yale's ROTC program are carrying forward
the proud Legacy
of those before them
this includes the Valor of nearly thirty
thousand yelis who served in the first
and second world wars Korea and Vietnam
and the spirit of sacrifice that links
these military men and women
is a Hallmark of the spirit of Yale
itself
it is a desire to serve to look Beyond
self-interest
it is the desire to contribute to the
common good
and it is in short the desire to improve
the world today
and for future Generations
indeed that is how our mission statement
begins
and this is the call
the class of 2023 has answered
your decision to serve our country in
the armed forces is vital at this moment
we can see the increasing pressure of
the spirit of division around the globe
yet today we salute your accomplishments
and we can also see a thriving Spirit of
service
it's a spirit forged over centuries
indeed the fabric of our nation is woven
by individuals who have defended it for
nearly 250 years
their resilience and wisdom
help build a nation
and their strength help bind it together
during difficult times
their courage helped save a world torn
apart by War twice
their determination is protected
Millions from a life of Oppression
and hardship
their compassion has brought food
clothing shelter and Medicine
to those who needed it most
and their unselfish motives in the face
of adversity brought hope
to those who are suffering
throughout your time
I've observed the same sense of optimism
courage and selflessness
in you
and I know the class of 2023 will manage
to make us even more proud
in the years ahead
now I'd like to congratulate all our
soon-to-be graduates
and express my appreciation to all our
midship and and cadets for their
dedication to service
and their many contributions to Yale
and their universities and colleges
you will soon be second lieutenants and
ensigns
serving as America's ambassadors around
the world
you will face challenges and
opportunities
in a rapidly changing global climate
with Incredible technological advances
that both connect people across Nations
and cultural borders
but also pose unpredictable security
risks
you will also experience shifts in
political and environmental landscapes
yet regardless of what trials you may
face I am confident that you like the
generations of yellys who contributed to
this country before you
will lead and serve the greater good
we're so proud of what you have
accomplished here
and we eagerly look forward to all you
will achieve in the future
as you build on yel's tradition of loyal
service to community
and to Country
thank you very much for joining us today
and to all of you thank you and please
accept my most heartfelt congratulations
thank you very much
[Applause]
we will now begin with the presentation
of awards
the Veterans of Foreign Wars award is
presented by Mr Mario Richards Veterans
of Foreign Wars Connecticut state
Commander this award recognizes one
midshipman and one Cadet who demonstrate
a positive attitude towards ROTC
outstanding professional attributes and
officer potential this year's Naval ROTC
recipient is midshipman Andrew turkleton
and Air Force ROTC recipient is Cadet
McKenna Picton
okay
congratulations
foreign
the general Society of the War of 1812
award is presented by Mr Lee Tryon
Secretary of the general Society of the
War of 1812 in the state of Connecticut
this award recognizes one midshipman and
one Cadet who represent the cherishing
maintenance and extension of the
institutions of American freedom and
Foster true patriotism and love of
country this year's Naval ROTC recipient
is midshipman Samuel Yankee an Air Force
ROTC recipient is Cadet Caitlin atlasnig
[Applause]
the Yale veterans association true to
her Traditions award is presented by Mr
Joshua Ray Yale College Class of 2013
and Holly Hermes Yale University
incoming liaison for veteran and
Military Affairs and Colonel United
States Air Force Reserve the mission of
Yale University is to educate leaders
additionally Yale has a long and
glorious tradition of service and
defense of our nation the Yale veterans
association is very pleased to present
its true to her tradition's leadership
award to honor and commemorate these
ideals to the midshipmen and Cadet who
have demonstrated a strong commitment to
them over the past year this year's
Naval ROTC recipient is midshipman
Victoria Smithson an Air Force ROTC
recipient is Cadet Nita Q
the Yale veterans Network annual ROTC
award is presented by Miss Tamika Hollis
co-chair of the Yale veterans Network in
the spirit of the Yale veterans networks
charged to connect veterans on campus
this award recognizes one midshipman and
one Cadet who have demonstrated
commitment to the Yale ROTC program
through outstanding leadership
discipline character citizenship and
academic achievement this year's Naval
ROTC recipient is midshipman Juliana
Calvert and Air Force ROTC recipient is
Cadet Grace zerva
thank you
[Applause]
the order of the Purple Heart National
leadership award is presented by Major
Daniel Edinger United States Army
retired in order of the Purple Heart
Regional commander and Mr Mike Perrone
order of the Purple Heart State
Commander this award recognizes the
demonstrated leadership ability of one
midshipman and one Cadet enrolled in a
university ROTC program
this year's Naval ROTC recipient is
midship mentori imhoff and Air Force
ROTC recipient is Cadet Thomas nardini
thank you
the rear Admiral Frederick B Warder
award for outstanding achievement is
presented by Captain Tom Olson United
States Navy retired and vice president
of the naval submarine League Nautilus
chapter the rear Admiral Frederick B
Warner award for outstanding achievement
established in 1986 recognizes a
graduating Naval ROTC senior approved
for entry into the Navy's nuclear
propulsion program as submarine officers
the awardee has demonstrated Superior
sustained performance in a difficult and
challenging academic and operational
environment and as a result has earned
the commanding officers nomination for
this distinctive award
this year's recipient is midshipman Dan
Nguyen
[Applause]
the Corporal Langdon laws Ricketts award
is presented by Lieutenant Colonel
Andrew gorgumis United States Marine
Corps and Marine fellow at the Jackson
School of global Affairs Corporal
Ricketts graduated from Yale College in
1916 and was killed in action during
World War One at Mont Blanc in 1918. a
decorated Marine who was the recipient
of the kradiger all accounts maintained
that Corporal Ricketts had a knack for
maintaining his wits in the face of
chaos importantly he was an enlisted man
a non-commissioned officer ncos are the
backbone of the Marine Corps more than
any other service the Marines Place
special trust and confidence in the
abilities of their junior most enlisted
leadership it is this sort of marine
that the recipient of the Corporal
Langdon laws Ricketts award will be
caught upon to lead shortly after their
graduation from Yale College this year's
recipient is midshipman Catherine yang
[Applause]
the Hiram Bingham third award is
presented by Jack Beecher outgoing
military and Veteran liaison this award
in honor of the esteemed Yale academic
Explorer and politician Hiram Bingham
III is presented to urge its awardee to
always fight for truth justice and mercy
and to serve as a reminder to all to
fear nothing except to do wrong this
award recognizes a senior yearl Air
Force ROTC Cadet who exhibits the
highest level of Integrity in American
citizenship this year's recipient is
Cadet James crossdale
[Applause]
the Robert and Tharp award is presented
by Colonel granholm Robert and Tharp was
an esteemed teacher and mentor to
generations of Air Force language
Specialists this award recognizes a Yale
Air Force ROTC Cadet for excellence in
academic achievement and for inspiring
others toward Global cultural awareness
this year's recipient is Cadet Isabella
skembry
[Applause]
the Yale veterans association class of
1966 sword is presented by Mr Tom o
platin Yale College Class of 1966 and
president emeritus of the Yale veterans
association this sword is awarded to a
naval ROTC student who possesses a
demonstrated leadership ability and who
has earned the respect of Yale
classmates inside and outside of the
naval ROTC program
through their efforts they have
materially contributed to Bridging the
civilian military divide and by exerting
leadership in both spheres have enhanced
The Prestige of the naval ROTC program
on campus and reinforce the Yale
tradition of engaging in service to
society as a desirable life objective
this year's recipient is midshipman
Kevin Walsh
[Applause]
the Admiral David S Ingles leadership
award is presented by Mr Redmond s
Ingles Yale College Class of 1998 and
Grandson of Admiral David S Ingles David
S Ingles Yale College Class of 1920 was
a Navy's first Ace with five confirmed
kills in World War one he later served
as assistant Secretary of the Navy for
Aeronautics where he tripled the number
of Navy aircraft while advocating for a
fully Deployable carrier task force at
Yale he twice captained the men's hockey
team the Admiral David S Ingles award
recognizes a senior Yale Naval ROTC
midshipman who shows uncommon ability
and Leadership potential this year's
recipient is midshipman Benjamin markert
[Applause]
the Yale veterans ROTC fund award is
presented by Mr Peter salave president
of Yale University this award recognizes
a senior in the Army Naval and Air Force
ROTC unit who is in good standing in
their unit with excellent academic and
Military performance records this year's
Army recipient is Cadet Alexandra rakov
Marine Corps recipient is midshipman
Aaron coo Navy recipient is midshipman
Joseph Murphy Air Force recipient is
Cadet Brian Regan
thank you
[Applause]
this year marks the first presentation
of the Yale veterans ROTC fund award to
a Cadet selected for service in the
United States space force to commemorate
this event accompanying president salave
who will present the sword is General
John W Raymond the former Chief of space
operations of the United States space
force the space force recipient is Cadet
Charlotte Vick
[Applause]
this concludes the individual award
presentations to our midshipmen and
Cadets who are undertaking extra
academic coursework undergoing physical
training participating in numerous
community events and willingly have
pledged to serve their country upon
graduation please join me in giving them
a round of applause
[Applause]
what's up
publish the order
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
20 2023
be awesome today
because of the day tomorrow
[Music]
baby
officers
[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen we will now
recognize the class of 2023 please hold
your applause until everyone has been
recognized
Cadet April Kim from Fredericksburg
Virginia of poly Murray college service
assignment Transportation Corps officer
first assignment basic officer leader
Course Fort Lee Virginia
Cadet Alexandra rakov from New Haven
Connecticut of Branford College service
assignment medical service Corps officer
first assignment basic officer leader
Course Fort Sam Houston Texas
midshipman Dan Nguyen from Falls Church
Virginia of Trumbull College service
assignment submarine warfare officer
first assignment Naval nuclear
PowerSchool Joint Base Charleston South
Carolina
midshipman Aaron coo from Diamond Bar
California of Benjamin Franklin College
service assignment Marine Corps officer
first assignment the basic School Marine
Corps Base Quantico Virginia
midshipman Benjamin marker from
Portsmouth Rhode Island of Jonathan
Edwards College service assignment Naval
aviator first assignment Naval flight
school Naval Air Station Pensacola
Florida
midshipman Joseph Murphy from Milwaukee
Wisconsin of Ezra Stiles College service
assignment Naval intelligence officer
first assignment basic intelligence
officer training Naval Air Station Dam
Neck Annex Virginia
midshipman Emily Quisenberry from Glen
Eagle Maryland of Grace Hopper College
service assignment Naval reactors
engineer first assignment Naval reactors
preliminary training Naval reactors
headquarters District of Columbia
midshipman Kevin Walsh from San Diego
California of Pearson College service
assignment Naval aviator first
assignment Naval flight school Naval Air
Station Pensacola Florida
mid shim and Catherine Yang from coast
Cobb Connecticut of Brantford College
service assignment Marine Corps officer
candidate first assignment Marine Corps
officer candidate School Marine Corps
Base Quantico Virginia
midshipman Thomas Zamora from San Diego
California of Morris College service
assignment Marine Corps officer
candidate first assignment Marine Corps
officer candidate School Marine Corps
Base Quantico Virginia
Cadet James crossdale from Burlington
Massachusetts of the University of New
Haven service assignment Air Force pilot
first assignment undergraduate pilot
training Laughlin Air Force Base Texas
Cadet Danielle Daly from Alexandria
Virginia of Benjamin Franklin College
service assignment remotely piloted
aircraft pilot first assignment remotely
piloted aircraft course Randolph Air
Force Base Texas
Cadet Pressley Hill from Franklin
Connecticut of the University of New
Haven service assignment Air Force
intelligence officer first assignment
intelligence officer technical school
Goodfellow Air Force Base Texas
Cadet Quentin Holden from the District
of Columbia of Berkeley College service
assignment cyberspace operations officer
first assignment undergraduate cyber
training Keesler Air Force Base
Mississippi
Cadet William Klein from St Petersburg
Florida of Brantford College service
assignment space operations officer
first assignment master's program in
Aeronautics and astronautics
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
Cambridge Massachusetts
Cadet Brian Regan from Redondo Beach
California of Morris College service
assignment Air Force helicopter pilot
first assignment master's program in
aerospace engineering Georgia Institute
of Technology Atlanta Georgia
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey of Pearson
College service assignment Air Force
intelligence officer first assignment
intelligence officer technical school
Goodfellow Air Force Base Texas
Cadet Charlotte Vic from Inglewood
Florida of the University of New Haven
service assignment space force
intelligence officer first assignment
345th recruiting Squadron Scott Air
Force Base Illinois
Cadet Matthew vitarelli from Bethel
Connecticut of poly Murray college
service assignment cyberspace operations
officer first assignment undergraduate
cyber training Keesler Air Force Base
Mississippi
Cadet Kate Yeager from Salinas
California of Silliman College service
assignment information operations
officer first assignment 352nd Special
Operations Wing Royal Air Force
mildenhall United Kingdom
Cadet Grace zerba from Dayton Ohio of
Saybrook College service assignment
Acquisitions officer first assignment
Eglin Air Force Base Florida
ladies and Gentlemen please join me in a
round of applause for our graduating
seniors
[Applause]
ladies and Gentlemen please rise for the
benediction and remain standing for the
pass and review service songs and
departure of the official party
my sisters and brothers let us go forth
from this place in peace with wisdom and
understanding with compassion and mercy
with courage and commitment
may we be blessed to this day and every
day by the shimmering light of our God
who creates sustains and Embraces all
life
amen
attention
March but demand in review
I serve
pass and review
right thank you unfortunately
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oh
my God
[Music]
foreign
it
I serve
d
company
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this concludes
today's ceremony we invite all
presenters and award recipients to join
us at Center of court to take photos
thank you for attending and please join
us for luncheon in the lobby upstairs
thank you
[Music]